[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un numéro exceptionnel des matins
du sénat les sénateurs de la commission
d' enquête sur la gestion de la crise du
coronavirus vont entendre dans quelques
instants
jean françois delfraissy le président du
conseil scientifique
cette instance composée de spécialistes
chargés de conseiller l'exécutif pour
les mesures sanitaires à prendre pendant
cette épidémie et les sénateurs veulent
comprendre le rôle et l'importance qu'a
eue le conseil scientifique durant cette
crise sanitaire
l'audition de jean françois delfraissy 7
800 scientifiques qui s'y rapportent et
les mesures propres à y mette un terme y
compris celles relevant de différents
articles ainsi que sur la durée de leurs
applications
ces avis seront rendues publiques sans
délai le comité 10 ou lorsque prend fin
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le conseil a rendu des avis public à
chacune des étapes de la gestion de la
crise avant ou après les annonces du
gouvernement
il est pluridisciplinaire et notre
commission denquête a déjà entendu
quelques uns de ses membres sur
différentes thématiques c'était le cas
d'arnaud fontanes et dans le cadre de la
table ronde consacrée à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire dans l'oise mais aussi
laisse dernière bruno lina
sur la question des tests et du
dépistage et nous entendons cet
après-midi d'ailleurs yazdan yazdanpanah
sur les questions de la recherche et des
traitements sur ces derniers aspects un
second comité le comité analyse
recherche et expertises dirigée par
françoise barré sinoussi a été mise en
place
il est chargé de faire des
recommandations sur la recherche ainsi
que sur des essais cliniques et
thérapeutiques professeur vous avez été
entendu à deux reprises par la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale ce qui me permet de faire écho
aux propos que vous avez tenus devant
nos collègues députés
nous sommes en effet aujourd'hui dans
une logique de retour d'expérience sur
la gestion de crise et vous avez déclaré
en conclusion le 18 juin dernier que
vous aviez deux messages à faire passer
premièrement il faut anticiper pour
mieux préparer
deuxièmement je pense que nous devons
avoir une
réflexion sur la construction et sur
l'avenir de la santé publique en france
avez vous dit pourriez vous développer
et précisé ses deux points ce matin
enfin vous avez déclaré à l'assemblée
nationale que le conseil scientifique
avait fait entendre je cite sa petite
musique
pour notre part comme nombre de nos
concitoyens nous avons plutôt eu le
sentiment d'entendre parfois une
assourdissante cacophonie de la part du
monde scientifique
comment l'expliquez ou chez un
professeur je vais vous demander de
présenter vos brièvement vos principaux
messages 10e 15 minutes maximum afin de
laisser bien sûr le temps où s'échangent
et les personnes qui vous accompagnent
pour un répondre bien sûr aux questions
après avoir prêté serment car nous
sommes dans une commission d' enquête et
il vous faut il faut rappeler que tout
témoignage mensonger et susceptibles
d'être puni d'une amende importante
75000 euros ou d'une paix et d'une peine
de prison pouvant aller jusqu'à cinq ans
ceci dit je vais vous demander de prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité de lever la main droite et dire
je le jure professeur delfraissy
oui je prête serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité je le jure simon
cauchemez aise
je le jure daniel benamouzig je jure
madame marie à l'aide d'art caroline
jacques guy denis malvy merci
je vous rappelle bien sûr que le port du
masque est obligatoire et sans plus
tarder je vous passe la parole cher
professeur beaucoup bonjour à tous juste
peut-être une précision
caroline est une jeune sciences po qui
nous accompagnent comme chargé de
mission
donc elle est un peu en dehors de vous
l'avez fait jurer c'est très bien
puisqu'elle est là mais elle est un peu
en dehors quand même du conseil
scientifique véritable je rappelle que
c'est la deuxième d'ailleurs stagiaires
de sciences po et que c'est à peu près
des moyens dont nous avons eu depuis le
début de cette crise c'est dans la
période du mois de juin
un troisième pouvoir médical bullshit en
oublie c'est uniquement dans les médias
il n'y a absolument pas de troisième
pouvoir médical
on est dans une grande démocratie en
france il ya vous êtes on et non pas
devant une commission du sénat on est
passé devant les commissions de
l'assemblée nationale les experts
scientifiques et médicaux sont là pour
aider à des décisions difficiles
difficile à prendre parce qu'elles sont
compliquées gpat dans le mot difficile
ça veut pas dire qu'elles sont
difficiles en soit le deuxième élément
sur comment nous avons travaillé
alors si je suis venu avec un certain
nombre de demandes du comité
scientifique c'est parce que c'est
vraiment un travail de groupe
c'est un exercice d'intelligence
collective ce n'est pas du tout se dire
est un homme seul
même si évidemment le président est mis
en avant pour des raisons diverses et
variées et tant mieux d'ailleurs n'est
là pour j'ai les épaules pour recevoir
les coups mais ce sont des décisions qui
sont collégiales et qui sont de
construction entre guillemets qui
aboutissent on arrive avec des idées
différentes et on construit de façon
collégiale
cet avis on a souhaité et c'est nous qui
l'avons souhaité que
on est des avis écrit que ces avis
écrits soient rendus publics
avec un certain décalage entre ce qui
est annoncé ce qui est donné au
gouvernement
et ce qui est mis public et c'est ça ma
part essentiel en termes de en termes de
vision démocratique secondes
ce sur quoi on s'appuie puissent être
partagés avec avec nos concitoyens
c'est d'ailleurs un mode de travail
habituel en médecine ces essais je veux
dire la décision maintenant est de moins
en moins celle d'un homme ou d'une femme
est de plus en plus celle de groupe et
les rcp en médecine sont faits pour
avoir des décisions collégiales et donc
on est vraiment dans une vision
habituelle
on a dit ce comité scientifique est
quelque chose de très nouveau
j'y reviendrai mais il est finalement sa
décision le mode de travailler et est
habituel alors on a eu que quatre grands
moments le premier si je me si j'essaie
de résumer pour tirer un peu des leçons
le premier évidemment dans la première
période
comment faire comprendre politique entre
guillemets qu'une dans cette période
très difficile 20 du 10 12 14 15 mars
jusqu'au 17 mars pour aboutir à une
décision de confinement d'un pays
je rappelle au passage que c'est pas une
décision saumon française et vous savez
elle est allée dans tous les grands pays
européens et qu'ensuite on peut discuter
du moment exact de la prise de décision
autour du confinement généralisée donc
ça c'est nos premiers avis ensuite on a
eu d'une ce deuxième période qui était
comment gérer le confinement et avec une
série d'avis autour de ça une troisième
période qui a porté autour du
déconfinement qu'elle était et là on a
commencé à quitter les aspects je dirais
de conseil média pour rentrer dans une
vision de stratégie autour de commandes
construit comment quels sont les besoins
les prérequis pour le déconfinement et
on a beaucoup travaillé à l'époque avec
le groupe castex avant que jean castex
devienne premier ministre
comme vous le savez il s'était occupé de
cette pièce de déconfinement et puis on
a une 4e quatrième période qui est
autour de qui est autour finalement de
deux avis stratégiques autour du
déconfinement ensuite de quel scénario
venir au moment du des confirmands
quelle place pour les plans de
préparation et de ceux de l'encens des
des structures et en particulier de que
l'état ne s'endorment pas pendant et que
les et des différents corps de l'état ne
s'endorment pas pendant l'été
et puis dans notre avis numéro 8 de fin
juillet
comme anticipé la rentrée et on a posé
sur la table le problème des 20 grandes
métropoles françaises qui à nos yeux
était un enjeu majeur pour la rentrée
plutôt d'ailleurs que les régions c'est
à l'intérieur des régions ce sont bien
les métropoles qui sont qui sont un des
points d'un des points d'attention parce
que c'est là où se joue la densité de
personnes le travail les transports et
et évidemment les des personnes les plus
jeunes
juste un troisième point sur les parce
que vous l'avez poser dans les dents les
questions que vous nous avez adressé les
relations avec les différentes agences
qui existent au niveau français bon
prenante dans d'emblée moi j'ai souhaité
qu' on ne que cet objet nouveau qui
était le le conseil scientifique qui a
été créée comme vous l'avez rappelé par
la loi mais qui pendant quelques
dizaines de jours était au milieu de
nulle part puisque la loi n'avait pas
encore été voté j'ai souhaité d'emblée
que ça soit pas rajouter une couche
comme on a l'habitude en france de deux
structures décisionnelles et donc on
s'appuie sur ce qui existait déjà et on
a eu des relations bien sûr avec santé
publique france le haut comité de santé
publique santé publique france la
directrice de santé publique france
était avec nous à l'elysée lors de la
réunion du 12 12 mars
j'ai fait rentrer le président du haut
comité de santé publique comme membre à
part entière du comité scientifique
nous avons eu des relations avec la
chaise avec la recherche avec reacting
éveillé en liesse d'avallon parlera cet
après midi je suis à l'origine de dents
dans une vie antérieure de la
construction de réacteurs sur comme un
modèle de construction et de réponse aux
épidémies d'urgence on a eu beaucoup de
relations avec la haine s m
avec le comité national d'éthique
au passage et je n'ai pas démissionné de
la présidence du comité national
d'éthique mais je me suis mis en déport
parce que je jugeais immédiatement que
c'était incompatible à la fois d'être
très opérationnelles dans une certaine
mesure avec la présidence du comité
scientifique et de poursuivre mon action
au niveau du du ccn est donc c'est la
vice présidente qui a pris qui a pris ma
place et ensuite avec bien sûr la cnil
on a fait un gros effort pendant le mois
de avril pas mars parce qu'on n'est pas
le temps d été complètement ensevelis
pour aussi avoir des liens avec les
académies l'académie de médecine
l'académie des sciences le cnrs avec les
grandes structures pour leur expliquer
ce qu'on savait pour comprenez je dirais
on comprenait telle direction quels
étaient les enjeux qui pouvait se poser
est de créer du lien avec avec
l'ensemble et puis enfin avec un
résultat plus ou moins bon je vous la
corne
on a
créer du lien avec nos collègues
étrangers puisque vous savez qu'il
existe un certain nombre de comités
scientifiques
pas tout à fait identiques aux nôtres à
l'étranger en angleterre en italie en
allemagne et donc on a créé du lien mais
vous savez que on a eu des discussions
d'ordre scientifique des changes mais
finalement que l'europe
cette occasion ne sait pas très bien
construite disons le puisque finalement
l'ensemble des décisions qui ont été
prises par les autorités sanitaires des
différents pays s'est construite au
niveau de chaque pays chacun a eu
tendance à se refermer sur soi même pour
des raisons sur lesquelles si vous
voulez on pourra revenir alors le
quatrième point c'est c'est la relation
avec le politique on peut se dire
ensemble que c'est une crise sans
précédent
moi je l'avais évoqué lors d'un
conférence que j'avais fait il ya quatre
ans plus tôt en évoquant qu'on aurait
une mutation d'un virus grippal et non
pas un corps d'un virus et à vrai dire
j'y croyais sans y croire mais c'est une
crise sans précédent et donc les les
relations entre l'installation d'un
comité scientifique et est installée par
le politique
d'une certaine façon et le comité
scientifique pose deux ou trois
questions sur lesquelles je vais revenir
la première c'est l'autonomie de ce
comité scientifique est ce que nous
sommes autonomes ou est-ce que nous
sommes dépendants du politique et la
réponse on a tout fait en tout cas pour
garder notre indépendance dans à la fois
dans notre mode de fonctionnement
je vous rappelle qu'on peut être saisie
par le gouvernement mais qu'on peut
s'autosaisir qu'on a joué la
transparence et et que on a été amené à
avoir des propositions qui n'ont pas été
retenu par par le gouvernement pourra y
revenir
le deuxième le deuxième élément c'est
que dans ce comité scientifique on a des
médecins et des scientifiques et donc
avec un modèle qui n'est pas qui dans le
modèle de la hiérarchie de la haute
administration française nous ne sommes
pas des énarques nous ne sommes pas des
hauts fonctionnaires qui doivent
répondre je dirais dans le contexte
français au à l'ordre politique nous
mêmes nous sommes des médecins et
scientifiques donc sans sans relation
hiérarchique par rapport aux y compris
au plus haut niveau de l'état et donc
avec une
libre et une grande facilité de parole
en tout cas ça moi ça ne m'a pas du tout
gêné par contre il ya des enjeux qui
sont qui sont qui reste fondamentaux
dans la relation entre entre un comité
scientifique et le politique au plus
haut niveau
premièrement la science se construit sur
les incertitudes et s'il n'ya pas
d'incertitude en sciences et bien on ne
construit pas de la bonne science et
donc on a deux pas en avant un pas en
arrière vous avez vu qu'on a il ya des
hésitations je comprends que certains
d'entre vous puisse nous interrogé
ensuite sur les différents mouvements ou
prises de paroles des scientifiques
distinguons ce qu'est la prise de parole
des scientifiques et la prise de parole
du comité scientifique
ces deux choses qui sont qui sont
différentes et on vous parlera tout à
l'heure de l'absence de régulation à cet
égard mais cette notion d'incertitude
elle ne plaît pas aux politiques par
définition qui a besoin évidemment
d'avoir quelque chose qui se construit
je dirais avec une certaine forme de
deux certitudes à court terme le 10ème
temps le deuxième élément c'est le temps
le temps des médias il est quelques
heures maintenant le temps du politique
il est quelques jours et le temps de la
science c'est plusieurs semaines ou
plusieurs mois et je les dis d'emblée
que nous n'aurions pas de résultats des
essais thérapeutiques de construction
solide avant trois ou quatre points et
on comprend bien que c'est difficile à
qu'on a intégré pour un décideur
politique de se dire qu'il n'aura pas de
réponse scientifique solide avant trois
ou quatre mois et le reste il faut
oublier c'est à dire que ceux qui
pensent qu'on peut avoir une résultat
résultat extrêmement rapide et bien se
trompe si on veut des résultats solides
la science monde prend un peu de temps
et enfin très très clairement et je le
répète à aucun moment sur à la fois de
ma part et de la part d'une idée vente
du comité scientifique
on a eu les bauges du début du
commencement d'une idée qui avait un
troisième pouvoir médical qui était en
train de s'installer en france
oublions ça nous étions là pour éclairer
sur des sur des questions difficiles et
on le reste et on le voit que c'est
d'actualité mais c'est bien le politique
qui décide
alors après tout ça la relation avec les
autorités et au plus haut niveau de
l'état s'est fait de notre point de vue
dans un climat de confiance et dans un
climat qui s'est hissée globalement bien
déroulé avec des relations bien sûr avec
des différents conseillers de matignon
de l'elysée du ministère de la santé
sous forme de note sous forme d'avis
comme je lai indiqué et puis avec
parfois des positions divergentes
on a eu des positions divergentes au
moment de l'ouverture des écoles on a
une position divergente sur la place du
citoyen et la place de la société civile
et on pourra y revenir et qui m'apparaît
particulièrement importante dans le
contexte actuel où il n'y a pas été mis
en place de comités citoyens tant au
niveau national et on pourrait peut-être
l'envisagé la maintenant au niveau des
territoires
on a eu des positions aussi un moment
donné qu'ils étaient pour le moins
nuancé sur la sur l'aspect de la
gouvernance et avec eux on regrettait
une certaine forme de gouvernance ne se
soit ne se soient pas installées à leur
dernier point peut-être pour sur le
conseil scientifique lui-même puis après
vous pour aller plus loin sur certaines
questions spécifiques
ce que nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes
pas une instance de décision
nous ne décidons rien c'est bien le
politique qui décide
on est là pour l'éclairer je pense qu'il
faut être vraiment très très clairs là
dessus parce que je revois le débat
partir c'est un truc de médias et c'est
pas un truc de gens sérieux
deuxièmement on a nous ne sommes pas une
agence une structure pérenne nous ne
sommes pas une nouvelle agence sanitaire
c'est un comité qui est liée à la crise
sanitaire
il faut qu'il ait un début il faut qu'il
ait une fin et je vous rappelle que le
comité scientifique avait souhaité
disparaître s arrêté le 9 juillet 2020
que c'est vous messieurs mesdames nous
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
accompagné d'ailleurs par l'assemblée
nationale qui avait demandé ce que ce
conseil scientifique soit renouvelé
jusqu'au 30 octobre
ce qui nous a mis dans un
je dirais dans un questionnement de
quelques jours autour du 14 juillet on
était renouvelé jusqu'au 30 octobre
on n'allait pas il fallait assumer je
dirais un mais après tout c'est un
conseil scientifique
on aurait pu imaginer aussi qu'on passe
la main à d'autres scientifiques c'est
pas ce forcément sur le conseil
scientifique et il nous a jugés en notre
âme et conscience et en tant que citoyen
qu'il était difficile de ne pas
accompagner en particulier dans cette
période d'été et surtout de rentrer nous
avions quand même anticipé des retours
du virus pour des raisons diverses et
variées sur lequel on pourra revenir et
qu'il était de notre devoir en tout cas
de rester puisque vous l'aviez demandé
jusqu'au 30 octobre
mais c'est une question de fond c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment créer un
objet nouveau de ce type et qu'on lui
confie je le sens bien
finalement une sorte ou qu'on croit lui
confier une sorte de pouvoir qu'il n'a
pas qu'il n'a absolument pas puisque
c'est le c'est le politique qui décide
mais la meilleure façon d'y répondre
on le crée et on le termine et on est
totalement persuadé de sa après c'est en
fonction de la crise sanitaire à quel
moment alors sur les le deuxième élément
qu'on nous ne sommes pas assez on a on
n'était pas opérationnel c'est à dire
que on est là pour guider construire une
doctrine construire une
une philosophie de la réponse vis-à-vis
d'eux et s'appuyant sur des bases
scientifiques autant que faire se peut
et je vous rappelle que la science a
évolué durant sept durant cette crise on
est il ya plusieurs exemples sur lequel
je pourrai revenir mais c'est la science
évolue et donc comment construites ont
finalement quand on a une science qui
n'est pas si solide que ça et qu'on
découvre en marchant alors on a fait et
vous l'avez bien compris
nous avons été finalement une instance
de santé publique
l'innovation thérapeutique et très peu
arriver jusqu'à maintenant la médecine
telle que vous la connaissez cette
médecine qui s'appuie sur sur
l'innovation
elle est très peu arrivent et elle va
arriver mais elle est très peu arriver
et les décisions que nous avons été
amenés à à construire et à faire prendre
entre guillemets ce quand il l'a
souhaité par le politique au plus haut
niveau
et bien c'est essentiellement des
décisions de santé publique et on
revient à ce que j'avais indiqué à
l'assemblée nationale comment ce comité
a fait finalement à jouer un rôle de
construction de la pensée et de
décisions de santé publique en france
alors même qu'on peut s'interroger en
effet sur qu'est ce qui manque au niveau
français en termes d'outils et de
construction d'une vision de santé
publique et c'est quand même des grandes
leçons qui doivent sortir autour de ça
écoutez je crois que j'ai est terminée
parce que sur sûr mais pour vous donner
quelques quelques points sur l'évolution
des connaissances et jeu une fois de
plus et je comprends très bien les
questionnements qui se pose de la part à
la fois de nos concitoyens et de
vous-même en disant mais dans le fond on
entend tout et son contraire de la part
d'un certain nombre de deux
personnalités scientifiques
alors d'abord séparons bien ce qui est
le comité scientifique qui prend la
parole
vous êtes probablement pas remarqué mais
au moment où nous sortons des avis c'est
à dire qu'on s'appuie sur ce que nous
venons de construire ou la pensée c'est
s'est écrite
c'est avec une vraie réflexion autour de
cela et puis ce barnum un peu médiatique
qui existe depuis maintenant le mi avril
qui s'étaient calmées un peu pendant
l'été qui reprend là depuis trois
semaines et où monsieur duchmol madame x
etc se croient tout savoir et c est
prendre la parole sur les médias je le
regrette daniel b la musique vous dira
qu'il ya et vous peut approfondir sa en
disant qu'on a une absence de régulation
tour de sarah et nous avons essayé de
d'essayer autant que faire se peut de
cadrer les choses mais c'est deux choses
différentes et je le regrette mais après
on touche à des choses complexes qui
sont qu' il ya eu maille à devoir
d'expression naturel qui existe en
france et c'est difficile
comment réguler ce ses prises de paroles
qui peuvent exister et après juste sur
l'évolution des connaissances un duvet y
compris nous alors par contre ça nous
assumons totalement
il ya eu des évolutions des conséquences
des des connaissances sur les mécanismes
de la transmission sur le fait par
exemple des gouttelettes sur les lieux
de transmission sur l'existence de
personnes super contamina trice
c'est au fur et à mesure de la
connaissance que c'est arrivé second on
a par exemple maintenant un besoin très
important de connaître qui se
contaminent comment se contaminent et
dans quelle lyon se contaminent vous
imaginez bien que pour prendre des
décisions
éventuellement si l'épidémie reprend et
bien de décisions eux je dirais
stratégique
s'appuyant sur de la science il faut
avoir cette science qui se construit or
elle se construit en même temps que les
décisions doivent être prises et c'est
là où c'est où c'est compliqué sur
l'immunité en population où vous savez
que finalement on est aussi d'entre 5 et
10% selon les régions de france de gens
qui ont été contaminés par le kobe des
cons des anticorps dans le chalet pas du
tout aidé par un psy je veux dire ça
paraît totalement naturel maintenant bon
moment on m'aurait demandé de faire un
pari sur l'immunité de population
j'aurais plutôt parié qu'on allait être
à 20 à 20 ou 25 % en france on est
beaucoup plus bas et c'est dans
l'ensemble des pays
donc voilà on marche sur du sable à
certains moments sur la sur la
signification des anticorps est ce qu'on
est protégé contourner quand on a
contourné tu fais un premier qu'ovide
probablement oui dans l'immense majorité
des cas mais on vient juste là dans les
dernières semaines de décrire quatre cas
de contamination de deuxième
contamination chez des gens ayant ou
ayant eu des anticorps tout six tout
ceci ces quelques exemples pour vous
montrer et et enfants etc au vide entre
est-ce qu'ils aient ce qu'ils étaient
particulièrement contaminants au
contraire comme on s'est aperçu que
finalement il était surtout contaminés
par les adultes et que c'était dans
l'autre sens ce qui se passe que ça se
passait ça a été une acquisition de
connaissances au fur à mesure vous voyez
que les décisions les décisions sont
difficiles à prendre
hum voilà moi je terminerais pour
d'abord deux choses remercier l'ensemble
du conseil scientifique qui a travaillé
mais de façon vraiment extrêmement forte
en a fait plus 250 réunions sur sur
cette période
le week end je leur ai demandé
énormément de choses et j'ai des en
remercie publiquement tous et une fois
de plus ce n'est pas du tout la sphère
d'un homme c'est la sphère d'un comité
et d'une intelligence collective et
c'est ça qui qui m'importe
le deuxième élément c'est que je
remercie les français parce que
finalement contrairement à ce qu'on veut
bien dire il a aussi les médias ont un
rôle on s'intéressant qu'aux 20 % de
personnes qui à des degrés divers
refuges tel ou tel chose et c'est la
majorité des français 81% des français
sont sains sont un peu inquiet se
demandent comment ils vont faire comment
comment ça va se passer avec les enfants
mais pas aux finalement portent des
masques on va je veux dire sont dans un
climat de raisonnable et soyons dans ce
climat raisonnable et puis le troisième
assez je voudrais vous faire part d'un
regret dans notre gestion d'un attrait
de la gestion de la crise que j'ai qui
reste c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les
ehpad où nous avions repéré d'emblée on
a et on a d'emblée donné un certain
nombre de consignes et de
recommandations pour la prise en charge
des anciens dans les ehpad
mais entre cette vision sanitaires et
cette vision vision de laisser vivre les
anciens on s'est bien aperçu voilà que
les ehpad était d'ailleurs beaucoup
moins médicalisé compenser un
premièrement deuxièmement que
l'organisation autour de la prise en
charge médicale dans les ehpad était
quelque chose de complexe
ce qu'on avait d'ailleurs signalé depuis
longtemps dans d'autres temps d'autres
structures et en tout cas c'est un des
éléments qui doivent bien nous faire
réfléchir que s'il y avait une reprise
du
ce dans l'est dans les semaines dans les
mois qui viennent on ne recommence pas
ce qui s'est passé au sein des ehpad et
que tout soit prêt donc voilà ce que je
voulais vous vous indiquez alors si on a
un tout petit peu de temps mais à la fin
après que vous ayez poser des questions
et que d'aimer mes collègues et puis
vous y répondre aussi si vous souhaitez
qu'on vous donne notre vision de ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les semaines ou
les mois qui viennent et qu'on soit pas
uniquement dans le passé eh bien on
pourra y est je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
effectivement une autre commission d
enquête n'est pas que examiner le passé
ou le présent mais également l'avenir
mais le présent est important parce
qu'on voit bien que ça bouge
alors il est de tradition après
l'intervention de nos invités de passer
les rapports la parole à chacun des
rapporteurs il vous pourrez répondre aux
questions et ensuite de passer la parole
à nos collègues où je regroupe les
questions de nos collègues je vais
commencer par bernard jomier pour ses
premières questions merci monsieur le
président je me limiterai à deux
questions parce que je sais qu'il y en
aura beaucoup aujourd'hui la part des
collègues d'abord je voudrais remercier
très profondément les membres du conseil
scientifique parce que je sais que leur
tâche est difficile que leur engagement
est entier et je sais tu cette audition
très clairement pour nous tous le
président savary l'a rappelé et
l'occasion de chercher des réponses à
apporter pour améliorer notre attitude
collective face face à une épidémie est
donc votre contribution vos réflexions
elles sont essentielles à cet égard et
donc les deux questions auxquelles je
vais me tenir vous ces deux sujets vous
avez abordé monsieur le président
la première c'est l'existence de votre
instance qui n'est pas dont les membres
ne sont pas en cause la qualité du
travail n'est pas en cause etc
mais que signifie quand une épidémie
flambent dans un pays parce qu elle
flambait déjà quand vous avez été créée
de créer une nouvelle instance ex nihilo
et de la faire
vous l'avez rappelé ratifié quelque
temps plus tard dans son existence par
le parlement donc sa création procédé de
la seule volonté du chef de l'état et du
seul choix du chef de l'état qu'est ce
que ça dit de notre système de santé
donc de notre site notre préparation à
une à la survenue d'une crise sanitaire
de cette ampleur est comme ça ce constat
j'ai cru comprendre que chacun avec nos
maux mais vous c'est un peu ce que vous
annonciez mais comment vous voyez la
solution à cette question puisque vous
avez rappelé vous-même que votre
instance était à durée de vie limitée je
ne sais pas si elle ira plus loin que le
30 octobre mais en tout état de cause
vous avez rappelé qu'elle n'a pas
vocation à s'inscrire dans le paysage de
la gouvernance sanitaire dans notre pays
donc le jour où elle disparaît si on
suit votre raisonnement que je partage
d'une utilité de vos travaux
eh bien il ya à nouveau quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne plus donc j'aimerais
vous nous vous alliez plus loin sur
cette question et ma deuxième question
elle est peut-être encore plus complexes
vous l'avez abordé c'est la façon dont
le débat scientifique dont la
controverse scientifique est porté dans
notre pays parce que cet élément dans
une période où vous l'avez rappelé où la
connaissance se construit pas à pas et
on ne doit pas juger trois mois après en
oubliant que la connaissance s'est
modifié mais cette construction devant
l'opinion publique dans une situation
qui est inquiétante a révélé des
modalités qui dépassait il me semble la
légitimité du débat scientifique et pour
parler clairement qu'ils avaient parfois
plus trait à la controverse des esgaulx
qu'à autre chose et il y à une absence
de régulation
est ce lié au fait que nous sommes une
démocratie la parole est libre et c'est
heureux et tous les excès sont là mais
quand les excès prennent le pas sur
l'utilité du débat et de la controverse
scientifique c'est l'ensemble de notre
population qui en paie les conséquences
comment peut-on remédier à cet état de
fait voilà je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président si
professeur delfraissy
je réponds tout de suite et vous verrez
le premier point et puis je laisserais
daniel bénard musique si je si jeanne et
des membres du conseil scientifique
c'est aussi pour qu'il puisse s'exprimer
nous sommes bien d'accord et je
laisserais daniel benamouzig veut parce
que c'est un des sujets clés qui sur
lesquels on réfléchit sur ce problème de
la régulation
sur le premier point sur pourquoi une
nouvelle instance
probablement parce qu'il manquait
quelque chose
il ya un long silence qui suit votre nom
c'est un alors je te rappelle je
rappelle que nous avons été créé à la
suite de signaux d'alert que j'avais
envoyé à l'elysée
la suite de dallas fois de la réunion à
doha baisse j'ai trouvé que les chinois
nous racontez pas grand chose j'étais à
l'om hasseni février non pas avec ma
casquette de scientifiques un peu et
enfin ayant une certaine expérience très
faible très beaucoup d'humilité dans
tout ça et y compris pour les comités
scientifiques du mal mais j'étais pour
le comité d'éthique pour les enjeux
éthiques qui allait se poser pour pour
la crise et c'est en revenant de la et
avec des collègues italiens qui m'ont
appelé et puis des contacts avec simon
sur les modèles de modélisation que je
me suis dit il ya quelque chose qui ne
colle plus et que donc des signes ont
été portés on a fait une réunion des
scientifiques d'une 24 scientifique à
l'elysée très multidisciplinaire aussi
le le 5 et le 5 mars et ensuite le
comité scientifique a été créé des
nouveaux danseurs dans le week-end et
puis après c'est parti
alors on aurait pu imaginer que l'état
finalement les patrons de différentes
agences par exemple santé publique
france le haut comité de santé publique
lâchait ce que les différents
responsables de ces structures se
réunissent en une sorte de comité
scientifique de patron d' agences
sanitaires pour éclairer le gouvernement
aussi dans cette vision là c'était un
premier modèle il n'a pas été retenu
donc c'est un modèle des nouveaux de
construction des nouveaux qui a été
retenu je suis mal placé pour en parler
puisqu'on est élève en a fait on a eu
les mains dans le cambouis en france on
a qu'on commence seulement à
s'interroger pourquoi on est là et on a
essayé d'abord de répondre aux questions
il me semble comme je lé indiqué que ce
qui con a tenté de d'être c'est quelque
chose d'indépendants et d'autonomie et
j'étais vous le savez très bien patron
d'une agence sanitaire en en étant
directeur de la rs pendant une période
et je vois bien comment qu'on est comme
on est patron d'une agence
on est à la phase soi même mais on
défend l' agence on défend l'outil alors
que quand vous mettez un comité de
scientifiques et d'experts qui sont
indépendants et où ce sens de la
hiérarchie une fois de plus est quelque
chose de
qui existe et dans la plus grande
politesse bien sûr mais n'est pas
directement impliqué il ya une sorte de
liberté d'expression qui permet de se
faire alors par contre on peut se dire
que c'est dans un climat d'extrême
urgence ce type de réponse est un modèle
de réponse et quand je regarde ce qui
s'est passé au niveau européen on a les
deux modèles on a des modèles de
création des nouveaux où on a des
modèles au contraire structuré et
s'appuyant sur des agences déjà
existantes
ce qu'on pensait début juillet c'est que
je veux dire l'ensemble des agents
s'étaient mis en place et avait avait
repris la main je dirais sur un certain
nom et que notre place donc été de
passer la main aussi haut à l'ensemble
des agences
bon vous avez souhaité nous poursuivre
on reste avec notre indépendance
d'esprit on est capable de jeu dire de
donner des informations et de donner des
signaux d alerte qui sont pas toujours
faciles données destinées d'alert le
plus haut niveau de l'état
c'est pas toujours facile non plus loin
et et je pense que ça c'est important
mais il faudra un boom à redonner une
place et pas toujours facile ce
président c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas
être nécessairement entendue non je veux
dire que c'est passé bien sûr on est on
est là pour eux je dirais porter un
certain nombre de signaux d alerte
mais par exemple on est on peut être il
peut y avoir des nuances et les enjeux
par exemple maintenant sur la crise
actuelle sont loin que deux ne sont pas
seulement sanitaire il s'est également
sociétaux et économiques et on est là et
on en a pleinement conscience autour de
star donc je veux dire que c'est dans
cette dans cette relation entre un
comité scientifique et les plus hautes
autorités de l'état
bon pas se parler parce que j'ai indiqué
d'ailleurs mais même dans un climat de
confiance une fois de plus je pense
qu'actuellement les différentes agences
sont que je dirais parfaitement capables
de prendre le relais et que donc une
fois de plus voilà on est prolongée
jusqu'au 30 octobre
et après on verra donc clairement
professeur notre système français
n'étaient pas prêts à la crise
alors daniel boehner geslin moosic
souhaité synthèse président je voulais
dit que le système de santé publique et
de vision de santé public français
n'étaient pas prêts à une réponse et un
tsunami de ce type oui la réponse est
oui oui daniel benamouzig merci monsieur
représente peut-être quelques éléments
complémentaires par rapport à ce qu'elle
vit jean françois delfraissy c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une situation on est tous
conscience depuis le début que tout à
fait extraordinaire par par son ampleur
et par de nombreux aspects mais derrière
cette situation extraordinaire
le point sur lequel j'aimerais revenir
je vous remets notion peut-être sur deux
points point sur lequel jean revenir
c'est qu'il ya aussi un caractère assez
ordinaire de ceux de ses manières de
fonctionner jean françois delfraissy
souligné que c'est assez commun
finalement dans le monde médical
plus largement c'est assez commun dans
le monde de l'expertisé sanitaire en
france les modes de travail qu'on a sont
des modes de travail de travail qu'on a
pour la plupart d'entre nous
déjà rencontrées parfois déjà vécu pour
ce qui me concerne à titre individuel
l'an dernier je travaillais dans le
cadre d'un conseil alors qu'ils étaient
à la fin un conseil scientifique et un
conseil de relation avec un certain deux
parties prenantes et qui est un conseil
indépendant sur les questions de
demander d'aider à genesis transverse
des membres supérieurs dont des bébés
sambre à la faire des bébés samba vous
vous en souvenez dans un contexte
beaucoup moins critique évidemment que
celui auquel on a affaire aujourd'hui
mais selon des modalités d expertise qui
dans leur forme voilà sont dans un
contexte extraordinaire mais peut-être
pas dans leur de leurs modalités ou
peut-être pas tant que peut-être plantes
qu'on la dise et des modalités de
régulation qui sont assez fréquentes
dans le dans le domaine de la santé où
on a besoin d' expertise scientifique
indépendante pluraliste collégiale une
autre dimension ordinaires sur
lesquelles j'aimerais revenir c'est
peut-être aussi témoigné de de
l'intérieur si j'ose dire du travail du
conseil scientifique on regarde tous on
est attentif et c'est normal le paysage
un peu institutionnel la place du
conseil scientifique par rapport à
différentes instances par rapport à
différents pouvoirs rapport
à toute une architecture
institutionnelle qu'on connaît bien et
dont on est assez friands d'ailleurs
dans notre pays et qui caractérise une
grande démocratie en même temps dans le
fonctionnement concret le mot
d'indépendance il dit des choses très
concrètes
il se situe dans nos modalités des
changes de délibération quotidienne jean
françois delfraissy faisait référence à
un mois plus d'une centaine ce presque
150 réunions ça veut dire qu'on se
réunit tous les jours parfois plusieurs
fois par jour jusqu'au mois de juillet
que pendant le mois d'août on continue
ce travail là et donc ont créé sur ces
bases là à travers ses délibérations ces
échanges ses doutes ses questionnements
cette manière d'aller chercher des
angles qui n'ont pas forcément été
examiné un certain moment et bien fini
par construire une pensée qui est qui et
collective et qui est un amalgame
finalement d'éléments à la fois connu de
certains d'entre nous parce que moi je
suis très impressionné titre personnel
par la qualité d'aidé de mes collègues
qui m'impressionne régulièrement et en
même temps il faut faire cet amalgame
entre geeks qui connaît ce qui est
fondée sur leurs connaissances
scientifiques sur leurs expériences y
compris de celle des cliniciens ou de
celles d'autres types d'acteurs et en
même temps de ce qui est pas connu de ce
qui est discuté de ce qui est débattu de
ce qui est très controversée donc la
délibération et de manière très concrète
aussi l'écriture de nos avis l'écriture
de dodi nous la faisons nous mêmes nous
la faisons si j'ose dire avec avec nos
petits doigts et nos petites et nos
petits bras c'est à dire que c'est un
travail considérable de coucher par
écrit et de stabiliser une forme de
pensée collective de faire en sorte
qu'elle est une forme de lisibilité cas
une forme de précision qu'elle a
quelques elle embrasse bien l'ensemble
des problèmes qui sont qui sont posées
et c'est aussi par une forme d'exigence
de transparence est une manière de
rendre compte auprès de nos concitoyens
du résultat finalement de de notre
travail scientifique que l'on s'attelle
quand une fois quotidiennement et
parfois très tard dans la nuit pour
préparer ces documents là pour les
réviser
voilà je vous passe sur le nombre de
versions nécessaires à l'élaboration de
chaque document mais ce sont des choses
concrètes que l'on vit de l'intérieur
donc c'est aussi là que se situe
l'indépendance c'est danser dans le fait
que nous avons la maîtrise de l'écrit
nous avons la maîtrise de nos
délibérations nous avons la maîtrise de
nos questionnements mère très très
concrète au lieu au delà des aspects
institutionnels sur saisine autosaisine
position hiérarchique et c'est un
deuxième point sur lequel j'aimerais
revenir puisque jean-françois mam un peu
tendu la perche c'est sûr et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est effectivement
troublant pour nous mêmes aussi cet
écart finalement entre le caractère
assez collégiale est assez consensuel à
de rares exceptions près dont on a fait
don on a fait état dans nos avis une
forme de convergence de points de vue et
d'un débat public sur les mêmes
thématiques qui lui beaucoup plus
controversée qui parfois même est
illisible qui devient rapidement
contradictoires et qui suivent des
dynamiques parfois difficile très
honnêtement très difficile à prévoir
anticiper même si au fil des mois on
voit bien la récurrence d'un certain
nombre de deux figures de schémas de
configuration que l'on dit en sociologie
danser dans ces débats là ce désordre là
ils nous frappent aussi comme n'importe
quel citoyen qui cherchent à chercher à
trouver de l'information tantôt sur
internet en tout à la télévision tantôt
en se référant à la confiance qu'ils
estiment pouvoir porter à tel ou tel
expert ce désordre là on doit faire avec
on doit faire avec les uns et les autres
une certaine manière il est aussi une
forme d'expression de l'autonomie et la
liberté d'un certain nombre d'acteurs la
difficulté tient au fait que sur ce type
de questions là on a une sorte de
conjonctions d'autonomie très grande et
très légitime d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs la profession médicale et
disposent et c'est très compréhensible
et c'est une construction historique qui
nous vient de loin d'une très grande
autonomie
la profession scientifique elle dispose
pour des raisons équivalente mais qui
sont un peu différentes également d'une
très grande et autonomie moi je suis
chercheur je suis chercheur au cnrs je
me félicite chaque jour de l'autonomie
donc je peux bénéficier dans mon travail
scientifique dans les questionnements
que je me pose dans les recherches que
je souhaite entreprendre et ces voix là
c'est quelque chose qui est partagé par
tous les chercheurs
de notre pays dans une certaine mesure
évidemment beaucoup plus largement les
acteurs de la sphère médiatique dispose
aussi très légitimement d'une très
grande autonomie dans leurs manières
d'apprécier les problèmes de convoquer
les acteurs d'organiser les discussions
c'est aussi un gage de notre démocratie
et sur ce type de questionnement on a
une conjonction c'est très grande
autonomie qui ce qui se mélangent qui ce
choc et qui répondent à des logiques
assez différente mais logique du champ
médiatique se sont pas les mêmes que
celles du champ médical du champ
scientifique et ce qui me frappe pour
reprendre ce monde régulation c'est
d'une certaine manière ça je pense que
ça peut appeler une forme de réflexion
collective y compris des différentes
professions que l'on a fait on a fait
référence sur les modalités de
régulation on sent bien que la
régulation est difficile on sent bien
que la régulation dans le monde médical
a été compliqué que les divergences sont
difficiles à régler alors qu'il ya des
instances qui sont prévues que ce
problème là se pose quasiment depuis
toujours
donc on a une vraie difficulté à aborder
ces questions là et particulièrement
dans un contexte où on a une forte
exposition médiatique
on pourrait dire la même chose des
instances scientifiques où il ya une
forme aussi de régulation sur laquelle
on peut s'interroger quel est le rôle
des régulateurs de l'avis scientifique
sur le la manière dont un certain nombre
de positions sont présentés défendu
organisé mis en place on faisait
référence à la recherche clinique
je suis pas spécialiste de ce domaine là
mais ce sont des choses que j'observe
on a eu un certain voilà polycentrisme
pour regarder des mots polis voir un
certain désordre dans la manière dont
tout ça a été a été mis en place donc
comment se fait cette régulation
scientifique à mon sens cela il ya
matière aussi à progresser
du point de vue de la régulation et puis
dans le domaine médiatique dans le
domaine de l'expression médiatique je
pense qu'il ya aussi
une forme de réflexion engagée par les
professionnels eux mêmes en premier chef
et peut-être aussi dans un cadre dans un
cadre civique dans un cas de citoyens
sur la régulation de ce type d'instance
les médias sont à l'affût des
professionnels qui ont légitimement à
défendre une très grande autonomie mais
en même temps on voit bien qu'il ya des
logiques qui peuvent être des logiques
mercantiles qui peuvent être des
logiques de durance qui peuvent être des
logiques de positionnement qui induisent
des choses qui peuvent être ensuite
assez problématique du point de vue de
leurs effets sur le débat en santé
publique et rendre responsable le
conseil scientifique de ce désordre de
ceux qui parfois est un vrai barnum ces
voix là me semble-t-il une forme de
raccourcis qu'à titre personnel en tant
que membre du conseil scientifique je
trouve à la fois être raccourcies
audacieux et un raccourci un peu injuste
merci je vais passer d'un jeune et c'est
bon ainsi je passe la parole à sylvie
vermine et et puis ensuite catherine et
on a versé
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
moi aussi remercier le professeur
delfraissy et les membres du conseil
scientifique pour nous avoir éclairé
durant la gestion de cette crise je vais
me limiter à deux questions pour que nos
collègues puissent imposer d'autres ces
questions porteront sur l'état de vos
connaissances professeur vous y avez
fait allusion
alors la première question professeur
vous avez déclaré le 24 août
on peut imaginer des vaccins partiel au
premier trimestre 2011 21 le 10
septembre lors de nos auditions ici même
le professeur lina m'a semblé plus
réservé dans ce domaine même très
réservé pour pouvoir annoncer des délais
de sortie de deux vaccins alors qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un un vaccin partiel
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
préciser
votre votre idée sur ce point et puis
une deuxième question j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur l'origine du coc vite 19
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous étiez une réunion de la ms mi
février vous avez dit j'avais trouvé que
les chinois ne nous racontez pas grand
chose lors de cette réunion
quel est votre avis sur l'origine du
colis de 19 merci de questions précises
preneur premièrement sur eux sur les
vaccins bon vous avez tous compris quand
on est dans un modèle de construction
vaccinale qui est très différent de
celui qui est habituel c'est-à-dire
qu'un certain nombre de grands groupes
pharmaceutiques
s'appuyant sur des recherches issues de
start up ou deux où de grandes
universités comme oxford comme comme
d'autres grandes universités a décidé à
la fois de d'expérimenter un certain
nombre de candidats avec ça donc de
faire les phases 1 2 3 1 qui sont
l'habituel et dans le même temps de
construire et de mettre en place les
outils industriels qui permettrait une
production de vaccins à haut niveau et
c'est donc quelque chose qu'on n'avait
jamais vu puisque en général les
industriels attendent d'avoir des
premiers résultats avec leurs produits
leurs vaccins ou leurs médicaments avant
de s'engager dans un processus
industriel est là donc c'est un modèle
qui est qui n'est pas d'ailleurs qui
retentit sur un ensemble de pays puisque
pour financer puisqu'ils prennent de
risque en fait ils ne prennent pas
totalement puisque il demande aux
différents pays et en particulier
européens ou aux états unis et à
d'autres de financer entre guillemets en
passant commande de 2 millions et 2
millions de doses qui leur permettent
d'investir dans l'outil industriel
donc ça veut dire que on a un nouveau
modèle ou en même temps que se construit
l'élaboration d'un vaccin et son
éventuelle efficacité ou non efficacité
il ya l'outil industriel qui se
construit
tout ça alors parmi les différents
candidats certainement pas rester sur le
carreau c'est à dire qu'on s'apercevoir
qu'ils ne ne fonctionne pas et puis
ensuite on a deux types de vaccins pour
le coc vite possible
on a des vaccins qui permettent de
diminuer je dirais la gravité des formes
des formes sévères chez les patients les
plus à risques
donc c'est c'est quelque chose de gai
pâte très habituel dans la stratégie
vaccinale et puis un deuxième modèle
plus classique est celui de vaccins
préventifs évitant la transmission d'une
personne à une autre
alors ce que j'ai voulu indiquer c'est
que on aurait peut-être mais je ne le
sais pas bien sûr mais compte tenu de
cette dynamique très particulière qui
aille de l'effort considérable qui est
en train d'être mené qu'on peut imaginer
qu'on est des parmi les mettons les sept
grands candidats vaccins qu'on en ait
deux ou trois qui donne des résultats
des premiers résultats dans le premier
trimestre 2010 21 et avec des résultats
partiels c'est à dire avec un vaccin qui
ne qui aurait une efficacité en termes
de transmission de l'ordre de 50% par
exemple j'ai dit ça complètement au
hasard
mais de cet ordre là donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec un vaccin qui permet de
30 d'éviter la transmission uniquement
dans 50% des cas là c'est déjà mieux que
rien et puis peut-être avec un vaccin
qui permettrait de réduire la fréquence
et la sévérité des formes graves qui
serait qu israël ait des non essentiel
puisque rappelons le cette maladie dans
90 92 % des cas et quelque chose de
relativement bénins et que ce qui fait
la gravité de cette maladie c'est la
sévérité des formes graves donc voilà où
on en est je pense pas que bruno lina
soit en contradiction avec eux avec ce
que j'ai dit on après c'est difficile on
n'est pas là une fois de plus le conseil
scientifique et c'est de s'appuyer sur
les données qui datent on n'est pas là
pour lire dans une boule de cristal
c'est il ya une part d'une part de
risque un peu à donner ce type de date
je pense néanmoins qu'il y aura une
évolution un tout petit peu plus rapide
que dans les stratégies vaccinales
habituel
le deuxième deuxième question sur
l'origine du coc vite demi de 19
bon je sais que ça fait l'objet de
beaucoup de débats sur sur
éventuellement un virus qui serait de
laboratoire qui se serait échappé entre
guillemets des laboratoires du p4 de one
non enfin je n'ai pas d'opinion là
dessus
1 le laboratoire p4 de one répondait
quand même des critères de sécurité de
très haut niveau ne
les technologies de chinois sont quand
même arrivés un très haut niveau
scientifique
après ce qui s'est passé exactement je
maintiens ma position qui est de dire
que les chinois nous raconte un peu ce
qu'ils veulent et que la communication
scientifique chinoise est quand même à
la fois et vos correspondants une
communication scientifique habituel avec
un certain nombre d'informations qui
sont donnés et elle est quand même sous
contrôle
sur le fond on peut imaginer qu'il
s'agit bien du schéma habituel d'un
virus qui est porté par une chauve
souris qui passe par un porteur animal
et certains porteurs ou le savent et ont
été ont été mis en cause
il ya une rupture de la barrière
d'espèce c'est pas la première fois
c'est là il s'est produit dans une chose
pour d'autres virus l'important et 7 on
ne comprend pas pourquoi il ya cette
rupture de barrière d'espèce qui est
l'enjeu majeur
je rappelle que les chauves souris
vivent très bien avec ces virus et puis
ensuite ça passe chez l'homme merci mais
la stratégie vaccinale
si ça ne touche que 50% des vêtements de
transmission enfin son résultat
pensez vous qu'elle soit sociétalement
acceptable et c'est que c'est une
science en mouvement et que on peut très
bien avoir dans un premier temps un
vaccin qui est une une une forme
d'efficacité qui est partielle et que ça
soit un premier candidat vaccin et qui
ensuite une amélioration de ce premier
candidat avec sa publié par exemple la
deuxième boost avec un autre candidat et
qu'on progresse en marchant ce que j'ai
voulu indiquer c'est que on n'aurait pas
forcément dans ce délai du 1er trimestre
2011 21 le le vaccin idéal que nous
attendons tous ce qui permettrait
d'éviter la transmission à la fois chez
les anciens à la fois chez les plus
jeunes et avec une efficacité de 99%
je ne pense pas qu'on arrive à ça je
suis même certain
on aura probablement quelque chose d'un
complet comprendra et on verra comment
on utilise mais aussi catherine des
roches dr nair ci faisait dans et je
remercie mois-ci l'ensemble du conseil
pour son travail pour cette audition
j'avais trois 3 questions
la première
elle tient au degré de connaissance bon
le conseil a été installé le 11 mars
vous aviez sensibiliser le président la
république
cette notion fin fin janvier la ministre
de la santé se basant sans doute sur des
ce que faisait l'inserm nous disait que
le risque le virus pénètre en france
était très très faible est ce que je
voulais savoir c'est si vous dans vos
domaines respectifs vous aviez le même
degré de connaissance si oui ça voulait
dire que peut-être les modélisations de
l'inserm en fait n'était pas correct à
l'époque
et sinon si vous aviez un degré de
connaissance différent parce que
certains nous ont dit c'est le cas à ma
surprise un peu de l'association des des
patients de nous dire que eux de leur
côté avaient très en amont puisqu'on est
sur cette période un peu un peu
incertaine qui était celle qui a suivi
janvier jusqu'à début mars où où
l'épidémie est arrivé de façon très très
fort dans le grand est le avait des
degré de connaissance donc lé tel degré
de connaissance et si le degré de
connaissance en france il n'était pas
bon qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
améliorer dans le cadre d'une épidémie
futur la connaissance de ce qui se passe
ailleurs
on a vu qu'il y avait la chine bien sûr
mais aussi il y avait l'italie donc
quelles étaient les embryons de
connaissance de traitement et autres ça
c'est ma première question
deuxième point c'est alors là je pars
complètement sur la situation actuelle
on a vu pendant la gestion par par les
soignants de cette épidémie notamment
par exemple la région ile de france a
appris ce qui se faisait dans le grand
est
ils ont appris des choses il ya eu une
période d'apprentissage qui a fait on
l'a vu dans l'évolution des des
traitements de l'animation dans la mise
en place d anti coagulantes certains
anti inflammatoires assez stade
moi ma question c'est maintenant si
l'épidémie repart on voit qu'on est sur
une situation territorialisée plus plus
lâche si je puis dire avec des des
patients et des clusters en aveyron il
ya des connaisseurs dans les
départements où il n'ya pas des grands
centres hospitaliers
est ce que quelqu'un est chargé de
donner des des modèles des guides et des
consignes parce que la chasse est faux
bien des réhab sentent alors je sais que
souvent les grands les conseils ou les
fiches pratiques ou les bonnes pratiques
ne sont données que sur sur des
assurances qui n'existent pas forcément
actuellement on est dans un flou donc il
ya une prudence mais en matière
d'épidémie nouvelle crise comme ça la
prudence elle a ses limites et elle
entraîne forcément des pertes de chance
donc est ce qu'il y a actuellement cours
des conseils pour qu'il y ait des
échanges de réseau un vrai maria un vrai
maillage territorial entre certains
hôpitaux et des centres de référence et
par exemple pour les généralistes au
départ ils ont été complètement excluant
des fois les os et mieux sur les
généralistes par exemple on sait qu'il
ya des biomarqueurs et autres qui est
chargé de donner ses consignes et à mon
sens c'est assez urgent donc je veux
savoir si vous partagez cet avis et le
troisième point ça ne correspond à une
question que vous a posé et qui concerne
les essais cliniques c'était comment on
peut concilier dans ces temps de pluie
sanitaires d'une épidémie nouvelles avec
des tâtonnements thérapeutique il
nécessité d'apporter une réponse
thérapeutique rapide aux malades parce
que les soins dans nos lits sont se
retrouvait face à des des patients et on
essayait toutes les thérapeutiques
existantes pour pouvoir les tirer
d'affaires
et la conduite de travaux scientifiques
robuste pour en effet s'assurer de
l'efficacité d'un traitement ce qui est
le but des essais est ce que est ce que
le ça a été facile à concilier parce
qu'on a des essais cliniques des bras
qui était purement d'antiviraux n'y a
pas eu vraiment de bras anti
inflammatoires est ce que ça ne génère
pas ça n'a pas plu généré une perte de
chance pour ce qui du fait des critères
n'étaient pas rentrées dans les essais
cliniques
voilà mes trois questions président me
coûtait je vais répondre partiellement
sur sur l'état des connaissances en moi
je rappelle que le conseil scientifique
et a débuté donc le 10 mars donc on a
trouvé une situation le 10 mars
je dis moi avec très grande simplicité
vraiment alors d'abord que j'avais
c'était pas dans mon agenda vous savez
j'ai j'ai eu 72 ans au mois de mai
c'était pas dans mon agenda de repartir
sur un truc aussi actif j'ai eu entre
les mains quand même beaucoup de choses
sur le vih
ensuite on m'a confié ebola et je
l'avais pas mis dans mon agenda c'est
donc
je j'étais avec une vision une fois de
plus de 2 des grandes conséquences
éthiques posés ces épidémies non et puis
je n'ai commencé vraiment moi donc à me
réveiller entre guillemets j'ai laissé
passer deux mois de janvier très très
très tranquillement en gardant comme
tout le monde comme vous comme d'hab on
est c'est vraiment cette réunion à le ms
où j'étais pour autre chose ou g où j'ai
trouvé que les chinois n'étaient pas
claires on les a eu deux fois en vidéo
conférence en deux heures on pouvait
leur poser des questions
il ne répondait pas sur des choses aussi
simples et volé des formes graves ces
kiss et des projets âgés ils sont anti
les combien de temps faut je suis un
technicien mois fondamentalement donc
c'est une question que je peux poser et
gg j'ai gueulé aux prêts à l'époque de
de l'om est 110 ans et c'est de la
langue de bois pour une partie de ce qui
est en train d'être discuté ensuite des
collègues italiens de la mi-février
m'ont interpellé et les italiens du nord
sont sont très brillants ses efforts et
on les a considérés en disant c'est
vitaly s'est passé est entièrement faux
ils sont beaucoup plus liées aux équipes
américaines que nous nous sommes en
france
voyez il ya ces connexions qui sont
extrêmement forts et qui m'ont appelé
dans ce milieu humide au logis en disant
s'il ya un orage inflammatoires des
cytokines que vous évoquez qu'est ce qui
est en train de casque est en train de
se passer et puis enfin c'est des
discussions et que les modélisateurs tôt
que tout ça pour vous dire que moi
finalement un peu quand même pas
vraiment et en plus tout à fait dans le
bain complètement et en particulier
auprès des politiques
mais quand même étant dans le bain dans
ma dans ma formation de scientifiques
autour des eaux autour des des crises
sanitaires
je ne me suis vraiment réveillé que
mi-février donc je suis très humble je
suis très humble un bon alors après je
laisse sur ces sur les modèles et sur
est-ce qu'on avait des signaux d'alert
sur les modèles et sur la partie
épidémiologique
sinon tu peux peut-être un dit quelque
chose je répondrai pas à d'autres
questions donc là on se projette en
janvier donc donc
c'est il ya beaucoup de signes d' alerte
en fait qu'ils sont venus justement du
monde de la modélisation c'est à dire
que l'un des premiers signaux très
inquiétant c'était une analyse faite mi
janvier je pense où les chinois
rapportait une quarantaine de cas
confirmés est en fait permis donc il y
avait 44 confirme 40 à peu près cas
confirmé en chine et par ailleurs si
déjà six cas à l'international est en
fait si vous faites juste le regard d'un
petit peu les flux de passagers entre la
chine et l'international s'il ya cilic à
l'international sait déjà que c'est très
très développé en chine et donc en
regardant le finalement le sait qu'à
l'international on pouvait déjà dire
qu'il y avait sans doute quelques
milliers d'infections sur le territoire
chinois et suite à sa très rapidement
après ce que ce que cette étude soit
soit sorti en fait les chinois ont revu
complètement à la hausse les
on commence a déclaré bien plus de cas
donc ça c'était un signal très
inquiétant pour l'ensemble de la
communauté scientifique
après ce qu'il faut voir c'est que nous
qui travaillons sur les émergence d
émergence y en a en fait assez souvent
et en 2009 vous souvenez sans doute les
premières estimations de la mortalité de
la grippe pandémique de 2009 elles
étaient à peu près entre 0 5 et 1% donc
ce qu'on a maintenant ce qu'on estime
maintenant pour le pour le comique 19
pasco tout démarrage on sait qu'on va
sur et on va avoir tendance à surestimer
la mortalité
parce que on voit que les cas sévères
qui vont à l'hôpital et que donc voilà
on a ce problème et donc il ya donc
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
a été très inquiète au démarrage de 2009
et puis progressivement on a vu que
finalement la de la sévérité et c'était
pas 0,5 ou 1 % c'était c'était plutôt du
deux pour dix mille donc complètement en
ordre de grandeur complètement différent
ce qui fait que je pense qu'il ya eu
tout un moment où on était un petit peu
en attente de savoir si les signaux sur
la sévérité allait se confirmer ou pas
et ça donc ça a pris un peu de temps non
si moi je regarde un petit peu comme ma
position a évolué pendant pendant cette
période là ce que j'expliquais c'était
qu'on pouvait en effet dans un scénario
de sévérité très importante avec le 0 5
1 % de mortalité mais c'était pas
impossible que progressivement on
s'aperçoive que la sévérité baisse quand
en fait on commence à mieux qu'on a
mieux détecter les infections donc yaya
cela on parle beaucoup de doutes et il
ya une période quand même de doute où on
était vraiment dans la tente aussi à se
demander si les chinois qui mettait un
moment quand même ont mis en place des
mesures sans précédent de confinement
allait réussir à stopper la propagation
à la source ou au contraire que ça se
propage à l'international donc il ya eu
toute une période de doute ou là la
communauté scientifique était un petit
peu dans en effet en attente de voir
vraiment ce qui allait se passer
il est estimé à combien la sévérité pour
le coc vide vous avez parlé de deux pour
dix mille pour la grippe de minerais
donc maintenant ouais donc en fait si
vous lisez notre avis du 12 mars
on estimait qu'il y avait une une
mortalité lorsqu'on est infecté entre 0
5 et 1% qui était à l'époque basé sur
pas beaucoup de données donc depuis on a
fait bien plus d' analyse
un encart dans les les patterns de
mortalité dans 45 pays ou dans quinze de
ces pays on à la sérologie donc
maintenant on a beaucoup plus de données
et en fait on reste dans ce même ordre
de grandeur entre 0 5 et 1%
sachant quand même que on est face à un
virus ou le le concept même de mortel de
donner un chiffre
pour la mortalité n'a pas beaucoup de
sens parce que toute la mortalité se
retrouve dans quelques groupes et que
donc bien entendu s'il ya un petit peu
plus ou un petit peu moins d'infections
dans ces groupes on peut vraiment avoir
un très gros impact sur la moyenne donc
c'est c'est contrairement à d'autres
virus faut pas juste penser en termes de
moyenne mais vraiment en termes de
distribution de mortalité passé 1 % des
décès durant la première phase 2 de mars
et son chez les sujets de plus de 65 ans
ayant une pathologie x ou y
sur ajouté donc on cerne bien alors ça
me permet de répondre à votre deuxième
question qui est est ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on a tiré des leçons pour la
prise en charge des patients vous avez
donné tous les éléments se dire que les
réanimateurs ont appris à mieux les
prendre en charge c'est un classique
dans les formes graves
c'est dire que les équipes médicales
apprennent et donc optimise le type de
résultats et en particulier d'essayer de
retarder la ventilation sur par
incubation
on a maintenant des résultats solides
décès alors la solide sur les
anti-inflammatoires soit les corticoïdes
soit dans une certaine mesure les des
antilles récepteur 2006 le problème dans
les faits de la co-régulation et est
donc votre votre question me fait pas
sourire mais gégé on a dans notre avis
numéro numéro 8 du mois de juillet on a
indiqué que les recherches devaient déjà
posé les questions dès début août pour
anticiper ce qui se passerait avec les
formes graves à la mi-septembre et je
pense que yaz en liesse en panne à vous
répondre à g vient je viens de vérifier
il ya il ya quatre jours que des
consignes qui donne des consignes c'est
eh bien c'est
alors c'est ce et des sociétés savantes
alors vous avez 2 2 types de conseil
vous avez soit passant par la chaîne
inquiétude qui est un premier une
première forme soi qui peut passer aussi
par le haut comité de santé publique
un sur certains aspects et puis quand
c'est très médical très technique c'est
souvent je dirais par exemple à la
société s'ils se sont regroupés entre la
société de réanimation
la société des infectiologues et la
société des anesthésistes réanimateurs
et des gériatres puisque ça touche les
patients les plus âgés et là ils font
des recommandations de sociétés savantes
qui viennent de sortir pour la prise en
charge uniforme est relativement
homogène des formes sévères dans
l'épidémie actuelle je vous ai répondu
exactement où on en est alors pour les
médecins généralistes y est on y est en
panne à vous en parlera cet après midi
il ya eu un flottement
je vous l'avais souligné et sur
l'organisation des essais thérapeutiques
il vous le dira dans le cadre de
reacting il ya un gros médecins
généralistes maintenant avec un médecin
généraliste qui fait partie du conseil
scientifique de reacting et il ya des
pour les essais thérapeutiques qui sont
menées et coordonnée à partir du mois de
septembre puisque c'est dans le rôle de
reacting mais ça n'est seul on est bien
là dans la révélation qui est évoqué
tout à l'heure ça vient d'eux seulement
d'être décidée par les deux ministères
et bien les médecins généralistes seront
d'ordre mieux qu'ils ne l'ont été au
mois d'avril ou ou s'est fait beaucoup
de petits essais etc
sur le troisième point les essais
cliniques
comment peut-on mener des essais
cliniques de qualité dans une situation
de crise sanitaire
j'ai pas totalement la réponse
j'ai même banc fin j'avais même écrit
que dans certaines circonstances on
pouvait être amené à prendre un certain
nombre de décisions qui ne relèvent pas
de l'essai clinique en 2000 je les écris
pour ebola mais rappelons que la
mortalité des mollahs elles étaient de
l'ordre de 75% au début 1 donc il ya
quand même une différence entre 75 % de
mortalité est ce les chiffres que vient
de vous indiquer aussi mon cauchoise et
même dans ebola eh bien on a on a manqué
finalement d'un grand essai randomisé
qui nous permettent de trancher
définitivement sur le type de
médicaments qui était qui était faisable
donc il me semble que y compris en
situation de crise sanitaire
il faut respecter au maximum autant que
faire se peut les bonnes pratiques
l'aîné qui existent en situation de non
crise sanitaire en les modulant et en
faisant que le maximum de patients
puissent être inclus dans les essais de
façon à apporter une réponse le plus
rapidement possible alors est-ce que ça
a été totalement réalisée
la réponse est non parce que c'est
difficile les anglais l'ont mieux
réaliser que nous puisque le système
anglais a imposé dans son system nhs que
les essais thérapeutiques
soit je veux dire presse partie
intégrante de la prise en charge
reacting l'a en partie fait mais en
partie seulement est il ya 110 ans pas
là vous expliquera pourquoi mais je veux
dire que la crise sanitaire doit la
réponse n'est pas seulement au niveau de
l'individu mais elle est au niveau du
groupe d'individus et on peut être amené
à privilégier finalement d'attendre un
tout petit peu mais d'avoir une réponse
solide donc concernant un groupe
d'individus pour mieux aller ensuite
traiter un individu donné mais c'est une
vraie question éthique un qui était de
l'éthique de la recherche et qui est une
vraie question
merci bien nous allons passer aux
questions de nos collègues douze sons
sont inscrits donc nous prenons les
questions quatre par quatre pour que
essayez donc merci d'être précis dans la
question
roger karoutchi le président mesdames et
messieurs du conseil au jour et une
observation simple la france
globalement y compris les morts à
domicile 40 mille morts ça peut faire
réfléchir et réfléchir différemment
simplement d'un constat philosophique
en réalité ce que nous ne sommes pas
trompés dès le départ qui a mieux réussi
cloud soit les états autoritaires qui
ont par l'autorité sans forcément avoir
une structure scientifique à côté d'eux
pris des mesures d'une telle vigueur
effectivement on a limité la propagation
soit des états qui avait une structure
scientifique mais qui ne voulant pas
avoir de responsabilités politiques se
sont souvent contentés de dire nous
faisons strictement ce que le conseil
peut importe l'appellation locale
scientifique décide et nous nous avons
choisi
curieusement la solution de ni l'un ni
l'autre
pas assez d'autorité pour prendre des
mesures fermes
un conseil scientifique et médéa vie
mais on s'empresse de dire que le
politique conserve la décision et n'est
pas tenu de suivre les avis et le
résultat c'est que nous avons souvent
louvoyé souvent donné le sentiment à
l'opinion publique on ne savait pas
clairement où on allait et ça ça
continue le tout renforcé effectivement
par des débats télévisés assez chaotique
où chacun venait dire sa part de vérité
ou
peu importe en tout cas le tout
n'éclairant personnes est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment qu'il eût mieux
valu quand on entend parfois des
responsables gouvernementaux aujourd'hui
dire quand ça les arrange
après avis du conseil scientifique et on
suit la vie
et quand ça les arrange pas on ne fait
pas référence aux conseils scientifiques
et on prend d'autres mesures est-ce
qu'il n'y pas mieux valu avoir une règle
simple le débat télé le débat médiatique
est ce qu'il est mais en revanche les
avis du conseil scientifique
objectif travailler j'allais dire neutre
par rapport à tout ce que peuvent être
les intérêts dans les débats médiatiques
c'est à vila doivent être suivies je
veux prendre un seul exemple très récent
monsieur le président et moi j'étais
tout à fait d'accord à la vue des
remontées des contaminations récente
vous avez dit la semaine dernière le
gouvernement va devoir annoncer des
mesures fermes et mesures fortes pour en
réalité faire en sorte que cette
pandémie ne repartent pas et puis nous
avons eu la conférence de presse du
premier ministre ou en fait il ya eu
aucune annonce
aucune annonce alors est ce que là
dessus on a pas entre le politique et le
conseil scientifique
un vrai problème si la pandémie reprend
ce qui semble être le cas
est ce que pour rendre confiance aux
français il faut pas donner le sentiment
que le politique et le scientifique
travaillant ensemble et de père et non
pas en étant tellement indépendants l'un
de l'autre
on se demande réellement où on va et
c'est olivier henno remercie monsieur le
président ma question est assez voisines
et elle part du constat qui a été fait
que le système français n'était pas prêt
et donc ma question est la suivante
selon vous est-ce que ça a toujours été
le cas
ou est-ce que c'est sous la pression
économique ou d'autres pressions que
nous avons baissé la garde
et puis en complément un peu de la
question de roger karoutchi
quel pays au singulier ou pluriel était
le mieux préparé ou quel pays est
aujourd'hui le mieux préparé je vous
remercie
jasmin oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président de précis j'ai
pour vous trois questions alors une qui
concerne les relations que vous avez pu
avoir avec les instances de démocratie
sanitaire
ce qu'il y en a eu la deuxième concerne
la vous venez de dire l'innovation
thérapeutique et très peu arrivent et
donc dans le domaine du diagnostic par
comté du dépistage il ya eu de
l'innovation avez vous déjà évaluer les
différents tests
on a plusieurs possibilités on les sait
mais quels sont les plus pertinents
aujourd'hui et aviez-vous connaissance
des moyens humains et matériels dont
disposaient les laboratoires de biologie
quand vous avez conseillé au
gouvernement de faire les différents
dépistages qui ont été faits sous les
formats les différents formats curité
réalisées à ce jour concernant également
le côté stratégique et géopolitique
avez vous pourriez en compte la
situation de la france qui est un
archipel en super france avec ses
territoires d'outre-mer et
particulièrement la guyane qui est une
terre française en amérique du sud
alors avez vous à un moment donné pris
en compte ces difficultés compte tenu de
la situation par rapport aux différentes
frontières parce qu'on se rassure
l'hexagone les zones frontalières ont
été gérés d'une certaine manière alors
que dans les autres mers sap a été géré
de la même manière
et concernant les anticorps vous en
avait parlé il y a eu au début des
interventions on a fait constater qu'il
ya des personnes qui ont eu une deuxième
contamination alors concernant la
production dont des anticorps et la
réponse immunitaire par rapport au
vaccin est ce que vous préconisez est ce
que vous allez suggéré qu'il y ait de la
recherche sur les personnes qui ont déjà
eu lieu coville
on verra quelle est la réponse
immunitaire et est ce qu'il y a qui est
opportun de vacciner ou pas vaccinés ces
personnes parce que là il ya une grande
interrogation d'après ce qui vient
d'être dit est-ce que vous avez complété
par rapport à ce qu'elle était dit par
mélina je vous remercie
merci annie guillemot oui merci monsieur
président moi j'aurais d'audition la
première question est un petit peu une
interpellation parce que on entend tout
pour effectivement dire que le temps du
politique est différent des médias est
différent des scientifiques que je veux
bien mais vous avez dit professeur
delfraissy que la science se construit
sur les incertitudes je ne suis pas sûr
aujourd'hui depuis très longtemps que la
politique se construit pas non plus sur
des incertitudes vu la situation
internationale et il me semble quand
même que le rôle du politique c'est
justement de gérer ces incertitudes et
donc moi j'ai vraiment j'interpelle ça
parce que ça fait tellement longtemps
alors en boucle en ce moment et ça me
suis un peu rebelle ça me met en colère
justement sur ces incertitudes il ya eu
la vie on a eu le docteur crozier qui
nous a parlé d'éthique et il ya eu la
vie je crois 106 du conseil du ccn
éthiques
est ce que par rapport à ces
incertitudes qui soit sur la situation
politique internationale on le voit
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se passe
turquie grèce et migrants mais aussi sur
l'évolution de notre société notamment
sur la prise en compte de la précarité
par rapport à des pandémies et ce qu'il
ne faut pas justement mettre en oeuvre
des conseils scientifiques mais aussi
qui font appel aux sciences humaines et
sociales et pas seulement économiques
pour qu on refonde un certain nombre je
dirais de commandes d'assentiment en
tout cas quelque chose qui nous
rassemble sur un certain nombre de
points
et j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre
position parce que dans la vie du
conseil d'éthique
on dit que le conte le questionnement
éthique amène souvent à confronter le
principe d'autonomie et l'exigence de
solidarité mais surtout les dossiers on
est au coeur la du sujet et surtout sur
les pandémies et je trouve que le
docteur crozier nous nous a bien
éclairer là dessus ma deuxième question
elle revient là plus terre à terre entre
sur l'organisation vous avez dit il
manquait sans doute quelque chose on a
fait le conseil scientifique
alors si on a d'autres pandémies est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas qu'on
réfléchisse à qu'est-ce qu'on change on
à la rs enfin nous on voit les
parlementaires on a le préfère en a
l'air
on a santé publique france il ya même
des gens qui connaissent pas du tout
santé publique france je me rappelle de
ce que disait madame busin lors de son
audition à l'assemblée nationale sur le
problème entre santé publique france les
ars clé masque elle disait que la
gestion du stock stratégique des masses
de protection ne revenait pas au
ministre mais était de la responsabilité
de l'agent santé publique france qu'il
fallait questionner le rôle des agences
sanitaires qu'il y avait des
interrogations sur l'ensemble et que les
compétences de gestion de crise la
réactivité avait été diluée et c'est
qu'il faut elle préconise une agence
dédiée aux crises en général et pas
seulement sanitaire
quel est votre avis aussi là dessus et
par rapport à et j'ai fini là dessus par
rapport aux hôpitaux est ce qu'il faut
continuer à fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
merci je vous demanderais d'être aussi
con si dans les réponses merci
professeur seulement que des collègues
vont pouvoir répondre aussi ce nom sur
la première question est ce que le
modèle français de relations et un
comité scientifique vis-à-vis du
politique un peu intermédiaire comme et
tu est il le bon par rapport à d'autres
modèles
écoutez moi je pense qu'il est encore
trop tôt pour retirer les leçons
il va y avoir plusieurs points il va y
avoir le le nombre de décès pour 100000
habitants qui sera qui sera un chiffre
bon ou la france va situer probablement
en cinquième ou sixième position parmi
les grandes puissances mondiales
je rappelle que c'est la plus grande
puissance mondiale les états unis qui va
se trouver en tête
le deuxième élément c'est le
retentissement économique et sociétal
parce que autant la question sanitaire
était dominante au mois de mars
autant soyez en persuader sur l'ensemble
des membres du comité scientifique
on est on est persuadé la maintenant que
les enjeux sont la fois sanitaire mais
aussi sociétaux et économiques et même
que dans le sanitaire
il ya deux sanitaires quellier oco vide
avec une reprise possible de l'épidémie
il ya le sanitaire cas liés aux kovy
deux mois les services de réanimation
qui eux qui ont été utilisées au mois de
mars et qui était une fois de plus à 90%
ou 95% dédié aux comics c'est impossible
maintenant marseille bordeaux ou fera
des choix de deux peut-être 30 % liée
aux communes parce que sinon on aurait
une sur mobilité liée aux nombreux vides
alors je dévie un peu mais c'est pour
vous montrer qu'on est totalement
persuadé on est des citoyens comme comme
vous ouvre et on est totalement persuadé
que le sanitaire ne doit pas être
uniquement dominant dominante dominant
et qui doit s'inscrire dans quelque
chose et 2 le deuxième élément dans la
relation avec le politique
écoutez moi je les dis en toute
franchise je les relations étaient eux
se sont construites avec une certaine
forme de sérénité et globalement quand
même
l'immense majorité des préconisations du
conseil scientifique ont été suivies
j'ai sauf sur trois points j'ai rappelé
on était on avait une vision un peu
différente de l'école et de la haie de
l'ouverture des écoles au mois deux
hautbois de début mai
deuxièmement sûr on y reviendra sur la
place du comité citoyen et de la société
civile dans le dans le dans le jir est
ce qui peut amener à aider avec les
rings décision là on n'a pas du tout été
suivi
et troisièmement dans l'évaluation
actuelle la de de la reprise ou pas de
l'épidémie on est on est quand même dans
la nuance
les réactions du premier ministre a été
et nous l'avions indiqué qu'il fallait
se s'intéresser aux grandes métropoles
et construire une réaction des
métropoles avec les ars les préfets et
les preuves et les politiques au niveau
des grandes métropoles
c'est ce qui finalement est en train de
se passer à marseille et à bordeaux
peut-être à rennes et on verra donc on
est on est globalement je dirais que il
n'y a pas eu de dissociation tels que
tel que vous le l'envisager mais c'est
toujours difficile à deux mois en tant
que citoyen d'un comité scientifique qui
a une certaine responsabilité et comment
on fait passer un certain nombre de
messages saab cérons et comment les
faire passer mais comment le politique
qui a une vision plus globale les prend
en compte
alors après est ce qu'il ya des pays
européens qui ont mieux marché que nous
oui
ah bon c'est oui c'est il ya l'allemagne
et à l'allemagne qui est qui et
probablement pour des raisons à la fois
culturel de d'organisation des länder du
nombre de lits de réanimation par part
pour dix mille habitants en allemagne
qui est très largement supérieur cloud
ou sur tout l'ensemble de l'allemagne
honda des ratios qui sont comparables à
ceux qui en région parisienne c est qui
sont ceux de la région parisienne très
largement supérieurs à ceux qui en
province c'est un c'est un des éléments
de la réponse
et puis il ya il ne l'oublié pas quand
même que dans les deux grands enjeux de
lutte contre l'épidémie
c'est la distanciation physique et la
capacité à tester tracé isolé tester
tracé isolé et sur la distanciation
physique
les allemands ont été plus sages que
nous c'est très clair mais il ya une
culture ancienne qui est autour de ça
des pays du nord
et deuxièmement ils ont testé beaucoup
plus rapidement que nous durant la phase
2 fin janvier et du mois de février qui
sont décrits sont des mois qui est le
moins peu critique comme cela a été
souligné et donc ils ont pu à ce moment
là à voir une pandémie qui est des plus
faibles et troisièmement il ya eu un
élément chance ou malchance pour la
france c'est l'épisode de mulhouse
on n'aurait pas eu probablement mulhouse
arnaud fontanet déjà dû vous le dire on
n'aurait pas eu mulhouse
on se serait trouvé dans une situation
probablement intermédiaire un peu moins
bien que l'allemagne mais un peu mieux
que là où on est arrivé début mars fort
sur les sur les systèmes sur la
démocratie sanitaire peut-être il faut
qu'on y insiste un petit peu peut-être
marie à l'été et daniel voulait
reprendre un peu ça et je répondrai sur
les aspects d'outre-mer après mais pour
vous dire qu'on a été très sensible à ce
à ce message de démocratie sanitaire
madame un mois mais c'est le président
mesdames messieurs je ne suis ni
scientifique ni médecin je suis
présidente d'akd et des quart monde et
j'ai été nommé dans le conseil
scientifique par le président larcher
pour que les plus pauvres ne soient pas
les oubliés de cette crise sanitaire et
je dois dire que dès le premier jour où
j'ai rejoint le conseil dans nos
réunions journalières
par téléphone j'ai été frappé par
l'attention de mes collègues à cette
problématique de ne pas oublier les plus
pauvres dans cette crise sanitaire et
vous pourrez le remarquer dans chacun
des avis du conseil dans chacun des avis
du conseil
nous avons à chaque fois fait des
préconisations sur tel ou tel point le
logement le sanitaire les les bureaux de
poste qui doivent être davantage ouverts
etc pour porter l'intention du politique
sur les plus pauvres dans cette crise
sanitaire
alors si si l'attention a été portée sur
un certain nombre de points comme un
certain nombre de milliers de personnes
qui ont été relogées provisoirement
puisqu'elle était à la rue jeu pour ne
pas prendre la parole pendant trop
longtemps mais quand même
pour vous dire qu'au début de cette
crise sanitaire il y avait dans notre
pays
9 millions 3 de personnes qui vivaient
sous le seuil de pauvreté qu'à ce jour
nous n'avons pas encore les chiffres
mais avec mes amis des associations qui
mènent le même combat que le nôtre nous
nous envisageons plutôt un chiffre au
delà des 10 millions de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
ce que je veux souligner c'est qu'à ce
jour malheureusement les plus pauvres
sont vraiment les grands oubliés du plan
de relance et que les quelques miettes
qui ont été distribués aux plus pauvres
avec les 100 euros d'allocation de
rentrée scolaire ne suivent pas du tout
tout ce qui a été suivi par le politique
pendant le confinement et c'est pour moi
une grande déception que je me permets
de vous partager ici
merci de l'avoir rappelé monsieur plus
dancing permettez ça ne répond pas à la
question que j'ai posée
il existe justement les conférences de
santé de l'autonomie partout sur le
territoire et il existe également des
commissions spécialisées des droits des
usagers
voilà donc été hors des missions qui
sont précises donc je voudrais avoir une
réponse qui ce qui se rapproche beaucoup
plus de la démocratie sanitaire dans le
cadre c'est de la csd la réponse doit
être complété un puisqu'il ya monsieur
benhamou ci qui complète
on n'a pas oublié oui effectivement ça
c'est un point extrêmement important
cette question de la démocratie
sanitaire et plus généralement du bien
entre les espaces professionnels disons
de de la santé et le reste elle reste
des citoyens dans la situation de
d'urgence qu'on a qu'on a connus qu'on a
connus au printemps force est de
constater que ce lien là ne s'est pas
fait dans les relations les modalités
habituelles selon les modalités prévues
et donc il ya eu à avoir une réflexion
pour essayer autant que possible de
pallier cette difficulté là je pense que
c'est cette difficulté elle interroge de
nous interroger tous y compris sur sur
le caractère sur la sur la capacité
aussi de ses institutions à s'emparer
d'un certain nombre de sujets elles sont
supposées aussi avoir une capacité
d'interpellation de participation active
au débat public et d'une certaine
manière ce sont ces éléments là qui doit
être favorisée je pense que ça ça peut
appeler aussi une réflexion
une réflexion à froid sur leur place sur
leur rôle dans le système de santé
auprès des différentes institutions
existantes pour ce qui nous concerne
encore une fois à l'échelle qui est la
nôtre qui est une quête une échelle qui
certes a eu un rôle éminent dans cette
dans cette crise mais qui ne saurait
résumer l'ensemble des institutions
sanitaires on a constamment appelé vous
le retrouverez dans nos avis vous le
retrouverez dans des prises de position
parfois qu'on a fait publiquement avec
un certain nombre d'acteurs du monde
associatif du monde sanitaire du monde
scientifique en appelant constamment au
renforcement de ce dialogue là je pense
qu'il n'est pas trop tard
je pense qu'on rentre dans une logique
on le voit bien qu'il ne logique plus
territoriale qui est une logique à
vocation aussi impliqué des élus
territoriaux dans l'ensemble des
décisions qui sont prises
il serait assez normal que dans ce cadre
là une parole citoyenne soit constituée
en tout cas je crois que nous y serions
très favorable nous sommes déjà à
plusieurs reprises prononcé par écrit
dans ce sens la dent dans nos avis donc
à certainement des éléments qui équipe
son améliorable convocation elle il ya
des choses qui ont été faites à titre
personnel je représente le conseil
scientifique dans un comité de contrôle
et de liaison qui a été qui a été créé
pour contrôler en particulier aspect les
aspects numérique qui est présidée par
par un éminent collègue et président de
la conférence nationale de santé
évidemment pas tout à fait un hasard si
on a cet cette conjonction là c'est
aussi une manière de de favoriser des
discussions avec avec avec ses
différents mondes cc différents mondes
voilà je pense que c'est un premier pas
c'est un mandat qui à mon sens c'est un
peu restrictif sur une question qui est
certainement importante et qui
mériterait une réflexion dans le sens
d'un élargissement
pour ce qui est des aspects citoyens
j'espère que ça apportera quelques
quelques éléments de réponse à la
question qui a été posée sur cette
thématique là j'aimerais si vous
permettez monsieur le président de
garder la parole brièvement sur sur
quelques autres points il a été
mentionné très justement que différentes
dimensions
sociale au sens très large du terme qui
excède la dimension sanitaire gagnerait
être prises en compte
voilà nous sommes deux spécialistes en
sciences sociales qui ne sommes pas
économique donc pour ma part sociologue
et on travaille en étroite liaison avec
une collègue quand une collègue
anthropologue qui a abordé aussi un
certain nombre de questions importantes
qui quel est notre rôle
laurent dans quelques mots d'ambon
essence ont un sens voilà sans trop
m'étendre j'insisterai sur deux points
le premier point c'est que presque par
formation on regarde tous les phénomènes
sociaux comme des phénomènes qui sont
stratifié socialement on n'est pas égaux
vis-à-vis de l'information on n'est pas
égaux vis-à-vis du service des services
de santé on n'est pas égaux par rapport
aux risques con con qu'on subit on n'est
pas voilà donc donc on regarde
systématiquement cette dimension là et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on peut être
attentif à certaines catégories
particulièrement vulnérables de notre
population pour des raisons médicales
pour des raisons pour des raisons
sociales c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est qu'on est aussi
très attentifs on essaie de l'être en
tout cas et on alerte et très tôt sur
ces aspects là sur des dimensions qui
dépassent des aspects médicaux qui ne
rentrent pas d'ailleurs forcément dans
des aspects économiques mais qui vont
renvoyer à des dimensions à des risques
psychiques qui vont renvoyer à des à ce
qui se passe malheureusement une fois
que la médecine a échoué et que et que
des décès interviennent voilà sont des
éléments sur lesquels à plusieurs
reprises vous retrouverez dans
différents avis on a consulté alerté
pris contact parfois avec avec certains
acteurs pour éclairer pour éclairer nos
points de vue et le dernier point je
m'arrêterai vraiment monsieur le
président sur ce point là il a été posé
la question de savoir si certaine
manière cette difficulté de préparation
certain degré d'impréparation qu'on a
tous ceux vécus venaient de loin oui je
crois qu'il vient de loin il vient même
de très loin
on a un pays dans lequel le système de
santé pour des raisons historiques
compréhensive débattues discutées à
différents moments de notre histoire a
été un système très curatif il présente
delfraissy
lorsqu'il s'est exprimé devant
l'assemblée nationale a insisté à mon
sens après juste raison sur le déficit
de capacité de moyens en matière de
santé publique
il ya des choses qu'on voit sert qu'on
voit que certains acteurs de santé
publique qu'en vue d'ailleurs leurs
moyens réduits au fil des années par
différentes lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale de manière de manière
relativement régulière mais surtout on
ne voit pas un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui n'ont jamais émergé jamais été créé
on a une santé communautaire au niveau
local qui est balbutiante
quand on s'est posé la question des
modalités par lesquelles on pouvait
imaginer des dépistages des modalités de
passage
on n'a pas des acteurs qui sont nombreux
qui sont opérationnels et on avait
appelé aussi une action dans ce sens là
donc dans nos différents avis de manière
plus générale la santé publique n'est
pas de mon point de vue personnel n'est
pas à la hauteur des vulnérabilités
auxquelles nos sociétés sont désormais
exposés le l'épisode qu'une traversons
aujourd'hui un épisode dramatique mais
nous pourrions connaître d'autres au
moins aussi dramatique je suis pas sûr
que l'on soit équipé et je suis pas sûr
que quel que soit son excellence et quel
que soit le dévouement des
professionnels qui exercent le système
de soins suffira à faire face à ces
aspects a donc vraiment cette question
de la santé publique en tant que domaine
de recherche en tant que domaine de
formation en tant que domaine de
recrutement d'un certain nombre de
professionnels d'organisations y compris
à l'échelle territoriale etc c'est de
très loin d'un seul question des agences
sanitaires et de leur rôle de
surveillance d'animation des expertises
scientifiques
voilà je m'arrête là mais c'est un point
que ce constat vous guider dans vos
analyses
ce constat malheureusement nous avons
vous et avec vous nous avons dû faire
avec c'est à dire que nous avons dû
essayer d'imaginer des stratégies
politiques ou en fonction des moyens en
fonctions en fonction des moyens que
notre pays a constitué sa ne constitue
pas en deux ans à ce type d'action que
notre pays a constitué depuis quelques
décennies
et voilà donc je pense que c'est
l'ampleur de cette de cette épidémie de
cette crise doit nous appelait aussi à
engager 1
direction de fonds dans le renforcement
de ses différentes dimensions sang
synthétique profession presque écouter
sur le carreau celles qui avaient des
questions sur l'outre-mer on a rendu
deux avis dont l'un des dès le début
avril donc c'est je me souviens encore
appelée même girardin pour pourvoir avec
elle commet et comment monter la réponse
en outre-mer et il aurait une réunion
téléphonique qui s'était pas en vidéo
qui s'étaient montés avec l'ensemble des
préfets et des directeurs des ars des
outre-mer ou au ministère d outre-mer et
il ya eu un deuxième avis ensuite sur le
déconfinement d'outre-mer et le problème
des frontières
enfin je veux dire et là on l'a pour
nous c'était vraiment à l'agenda de
l'ensemble et de ce qui a pu se passer
par ailleurs simon a beaucoup travaillé
sur les modèles pour la réponse en
guyane au moment de 2,2 fin juillet
début août
il a été très impliqué sur les sur les
modèles de construction et de réponses
qui pouvait être donné en guyane qui au
passage est un élément positif dans tout
ce parce que ça montre que à la fois la
guyane et ce qui a pu se passer en
mayenne par exemple montrent que quand
on cerne bien les questions qu'on pose
bien sûr la table avec le territoire une
série de mesures qui sont à prendre
on peut être efficace je veux dire il
faut pas être perdant permanence et il
faut savoir reprendre la main et on peut
parfaitement le faire donc c'est quelque
chose qui peut parfaitement se
travailler même même si je reconnais que
c'est pas facile pour les populations
qui sont qui ont été sur qui ont été sur
place survie' avez une question sur la
recherche en immunologie oui bien sûr
imaginez que la réponse immunitaire des
sujets qu'ils ont fait à que vides fait
l'objet de beaucoup d'études
elle fait même l'objet des ddc
thérapeutique pour regarder si les
anticorps issu des patients convalescent
pourrait aider à guérir entre guillemets
les et réduire la sévérité des formes
graves et il ya un essai qui est menée
en france il ya des données qui sont
sortis également en italie aux états
unis et ça permet d'anticiper un peu ce
que peut être une réponse vaccinale
comme je dirais marqueurs prédictifs
haut niveau au niveau immunologique donc
oui à votre question il ya plein de
choses qui se font
la notion d'incertitude oui c'est vrai
que probablement mais c'est vous qui le
dites c'est vous qu'êtes politique de
dire que le politique et vit avec
l'incertitude je ne sais pas moi de le
dire moi je dis ce que la communauté
scientifique que vit avec l'incertitude
mais raison plus si l'incertitude vie si
le politique vit avec un peu
d'incertitude comme on fait rejoindre
deux forme d'incertitude et c'est bien
là et c'est bien là la complexité du
dialogue un aimé mais qui à mon avis
tout à fait faisable et ça pose toute la
question de finalement d'une réflexion
de la réponse aux crises et c'est la
question vous posiez qui à mes yeux
s'ils devaient se monter une structure
et une nouvelle agence entre guillemets
ou un machin à la française ne devrait
pas être uniquement confiné aux crises
sanitaires
il devrait y avoir une réflexion plus
globale de la capacité d'un certain
nombre de gens à raisonner à froid sur
la réponse à la crise avec un don on le
voit bien
probablement plus que notre génération
enfin ma génération est une génération
bénie des dieux qui est qui qui a eu 40
ans devant elle finalement avec eux avec
des aspects extrêmement positifs dont je
comprends la jeunesse actuelle qui dit
mais après tout vous avez vécu une vie
extraordinaire
laissez nous vivre là maintenant et et
vous confirmez vous coincez c'est quand
même ça qu'on entend un tout petit peu
dans une certaine mesure
eh bien je dis que on est depuis
maintenant une quand on regarde entre
les crises économiques
les crises sanitaires on est dans des
enjeux de crises successives et
probablement il ya une certaine forme de
professionnalisation et de capacité de
sur le plan multidisciplinaire a réponse
à ces crises et qui doit être à côté du
politique c'est le politique qui doit
décider bien sûr toujours
et qui doit être capable de lui fournir
de l'information de la réponse aux
crises et un certain nombre de modalités
d'information donc sur la sueur faut-il
créer une agence j'en sais rien je par
contre je rejoins totalement ce qu'a dit
daniel en termes sanitaires ce qui sort
de cette crise c'est le problème
finalement d'une réorganisation de la
santé publique en france
et je vous rappelle que ça ça va très
loin c'est à dire que si je regarde le
modèle anglo saxon modèle allemand c'est
reprenons les les pays comme un tout
petit peu mieux réussi que nous si je
peux dire la santé publique n'est pas
intégrée à la santé il ya des facultés
de santé publique qui sont en dehors des
facultés de médecine et donc ça va très
loin dans la formation il n'y a pas
besoin d'être médecin pour faire
forcément de la santé publique il ya des
formations en sciences po actuellement
où les formations à l'essec
tout ça devant d'être rassemblés et
probablement avoir une nouvelle vision
de la santé publique et on avait été
assez loin puisque quelques-uns d'entre
nous sait on souhaitait même que se
constitue finalement une sorte de
secrétariat d'état à la santé publique
qui ne soit pas rattachée au ministère
de la santé mais rattaché à matignon
tout à fait mais le sénat travaille sur
différentes hypothèses on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir
merci pour les réponses nous allons
passer à la deuxième salve âge je vous
demande plus que jamais d'être concis
car il ya une troisième salve laurence
cohen un oui merci monsieur le président
merci aux interventions des banques du
comité scientifique et monsieur
delfraissy alors moi je vais essayer
d'être à pied quatre questions on entend
on entend parler de la mutation du virus
qui fait dire à certains que peut-être
qu'il serait moins moins actifs moins
dangereux et c'est donc j'aimerais avoir
des précisions là dessus en sachant
qu'il est toujours difficile
effectivement d'avoir une information
qui soit effectivement étayé
qui n'entraîne pas un surcroît de peur à
la fois donc qui alerte mais sans en
rajouter
or on voit que c'est compliqué le rôle
des médias là dessus est aussi assez
difficile et j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment parce que comme tout
parlementaire je pense qu on a on a fait
en cette rentrée le tour des écoles et
j'ai trouvé les directions d'école en
tout cas de ma ville extrêmement
inquiète parce qu'elles ne savent pas
quoi faire face à des enfants qui ce qui
va c'est naturel on est qui coule tous
etc
les rhumes voilà et c'était assez
frappant certaines directrice tout de
suite alertant les médecins donc tout de
suite des tests ou de suites etc et
d'autres disant bon bah on va attendre
un peu mais en tout cas complètement
désemparé donc quel est ce que là vous
avez en temps en tant que don comité
scientifique des recommandations qui
peuvent aider ces professionnels
deuxième deuxième question vous avez
recommandé effectivement une protection
je vais le dire pour aller vite par
rapport à un certain nombre de deux
personnes fragiles et notamment face à
certaines pathologies
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que sa
rente en totale contradiction avec le
décret qui a été pris et qui exclut donc
des personnes fragiles un certain nombre
de pathologies je pense à elle l'obésité
etc pour les leurs les contraindre à ne
pas aller travailler et ne pas pratiquer
le télétravail 3e troisième question
vous avez dit que effectivement il ya
besoin de revisiter c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
le notre système de santé or nous avons
été alertés lors de nos différentes
auditions par le fait que pendant toute
la crise aiguë de l'aco vide
il ya eu beaucoup de déprogrammation de
d'opération il ya eu beaucoup aussi de
renoncement aux soins par peur et il
semblerait que la com ont à nouveau une
on va dire une reprise je sais pas si ça
arrêtez de la de la pandémie est ce
qu'on n'a pas un risque de déprogrammer
à nouveau des des opérations et qui
mettent la vie des personnes en danger
enfin la dernière la dernière question
vous avez parlé des vaccins un petit peu
des traitements moi j'ai été quand même
frappé par le fait que vous avez dit
qu'il y avait une modification de la
stratégie et que les laboratoires ont
sont en première ligne
est ce que vous ne pensez pas justement
que les différences d état se trouve un
peu pieds et poings liés par rapport aux
politiques des grands labos et est-ce
que ça n'est pas le moment de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait 1 1
comment dirais-je un grand pôle public
du médicament et de la recherche pour
développer un certain nombre de
médicaments éventuellement également des
vaccins
merci merci angèle préville merci
monsieur le président quand je vais
d'abord reprendre une des dernières
interventions du professeur delfraissy
parce que c'est la question que je
voulais lui poser justement et pour pour
évoquer le fait que dans certains pays
il existe des instances scientifiques
qui sont attachés au gouvernement et qui
permettent d'avoir une grande réactivité
puisque je les ai rencontrés dans le
cadre de l'opex notamment à nantes je
pense que ça s'appelle comme ça le
scientifique en chef à québec au québec
donc c'est dans les pays anglo-saxons et
donc évidemment parce que moi je
je serais pour qu'on mette en place ce
genre de choses c'est à dire d'avoir un
scientifique en chef ou pas et qu'on ait
autour de lui pas des gens qui soient en
permanence là mais toute une liste de
scientifiques qu'on pourrait mettre à
contribution puisque comme vous l'avez
dit on a certainement dans l'avenir on
va espérer que non mais on va devoir
faire face à des crises différentes qui
devront mobiliser des scientifiques
différents des géologues des chimistes
des physiciens et c'est donc voilà
est-ce que vous pensez que ce serait une
bonne chose de faire est en quelque
sorte puisque je n'aime pas trop
l'appeler comme ça mais cultiver une
espèce de culture du risque qui est
manque un peu peut-être dans notre pays
alors ma deuxième question va au sujet
des ehpad
alors vous avez émis un regret de et
vous avez dit ne pas vouloir recommencer
est-ce que ce regret c'est sûr là
quelque part sur la faute d'humanité par
rapport aux personnes âgées
est ce que parce que moi j'ai eu dans
mon entourage une personne âgée de kim
est très proche de 84 ans qui m'a dit
que de toute façon si c'était de lui
interdire à près de sortir et cetera ne
le ferai pas elle ne voudrait pas le
faire et qu'elle avait écrite est tout à
fait capable de choisir celles se
mettait en danger ou pas parce qu'elle
vit elle vient la maison affiche est
celle donc voilà qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cesse de ce que je viens de
vous dire
et enfin effectivement la santé publique
a subi ces dernières années une logique
comptable et moi je m'interrogeais sur
les nombre de lits en réanimation
actuellement parce que vous
vous avez tous dit qu en allemagne la
réussite était meilleur parce que et que
notamment il y avait plus de lits de
réanimation par rapport au nombre
d'habitants
mais est-ce qu'on a changé ceci nous
depuis le mois de mars et est ce que ça
faisait partie de vos de vos conseils
d'augmenter les lits et moi j'ai cru
entendre hier ou avant-hier un an gentil
je prends je ne sais plus un médecin
dire qu'en fait rien n'avait changé et
qu'on avait toujours le même nombre de
lits de réanimation
voilà journée mais c'est l'artt un
lévrier
merci monsieur le président merci
professeur es et merci à tous les
membres du conseil scientifique
quatre questions rapides la première le
30 octobre c'est demain c'est le jour de
la sainte bien venu d'ailleurs donc
faut-il redire bienvenue au conseil tel
qu'il est ou avez vous des pistes
d'amélioration pour ce conseil si
nécessaire deuxième question vous avez
parlé aussi de la presse avec son effet
loupe ou revoir son effet déformant des
à cela est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que le conseil a bien communiqué en
tenant compte de ces éléments là où
faut-il là aussi améliorer la
communication du conseil par rapport à
la presse
troisième question il ya eu un grand
débat en france je le résume je ne suis
pas scientifique ni médecin mais entre
une méthode empirique proposée par
certains et puis les méthodes classiques
mais d'autres récentes avec le double
aveugle avec etc
cette controverse est devenu un
véritable combat en france qui angoisse
et beaucoup de français d'ailleurs ne
faut-il pas en tant que scientifique que
vous repreniez tous le chemin de la
discussion pour éviter ce genre de
combat qui ne qui nuisent en fait à une
bonne communication et qui inquiète les
français et pour des médecins c'est
toujours embêtant d'inquiéter les
français et dernière question qui
rejoint aussi la question d'un bréville
sur les ehpad et sur les maisons de
santé de retraite pardon je vais là je
pose la question sera quasi caricatural
mais je pense qu'elle est importante
ou vaut-il mieux mourir du coc vide
entourée de l'amour de ses proches ou
vous tenu mourir sol de la solitude ou
voilà c'est un pas très important merci
beaucoup
emmanuel capus mallet merci monsieur le
président donc on est devant une
commission denquête donc j'ai donc
commission d enquête çà enquête à charge
et à décharge donc j'ai donc une
question a chargé une question à
décharge
parce que pour connaître les
améliorations il faut aussi savoir ce
qui a fonctionné
c'est une enquête
ça n'est pas aimé jeu je préfère dire
l'état d'esprit dans lequel je pose ma
question
une enquête se fait à charge et à
décharge je le répète elle ne vêlent
vise les dysfonctionnements je m'exprime
différemment elle vise les
dysfonctionnements et elle vise aussi
les bon fonctionnement voilà je vais
trouver un accord avec mon école l'asie
donc dans les 10 dans les
dysfonctionnements
il me semble monsieur le président que
la position du comité scientifique a
évolué au fil des mois sur l'usagé du
masque
c'est une question que nous avons eu
beaucoup dans les mois qui sont qui ont
passé la question est extrêmement simple
est-ce que la position et les
recommandations du comité scientifique a
évolué en fonction de l'état du stock de
masques dans le pays ou pas très
concrètement est ce que quand il n'y
avait pas de masque le comité
scientifique recommandait ne
recommandait pas leur usage est
maintenant qu'il y en a le comité
scientifique recommande t-il leur usage
voilà c'est ma première question vous
avez compris que c'était plutôt la
question à charge une question plutôt à
décharge sur les bon fonctionnement
président savary a dit que le système
français n'était n'était pas prêt
n'avait pas réussi à faire face et vous
avez accès s'est cependant quand on se
regarde forcément on se désole roger
karoutchi tout à l'heure à 10 40 mille
morts c'est extrêmement dramatique mais
quant au second quand on se compare on
se console
vous avez parlé de la situation de
l'allemagne avec le cas particulier du
cas de mulhouse
et puis sans doute une préparation du
système sanitaire
et une mentalité différente du peuple
français mais il y a aussi dans notre
entourage immédiat je parle pas des
situations avec des régimes politiques
différents dans notre entourage immédiat
des pays comme l'italie l'espagne le
royaume uni dont le système sanitaire
semble avoir été submergé ce qui n'a pas
été notre cas
donc ma question au titre des choses qui
ont bien fonctionné c'est qu'est ce qui
a permis bien que nous ne soyons pas
prêts à faire face à cette crise de
mieux gérer la crise que l'espagne que
l'italie ou que le royaume uni merci
céline voilà pour cette audition de
jean-françois delfraissy le président du
conseil scientifique
auditionné par la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur la gestion de la crise du
cornet virus c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous à 15 heures avec l'audition
du professeur didier raoult et devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat
une audition à suivre en direct sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
et sur notre page facebook très bonne
journée sur public sénat
[Musique]